I can reveal that that Britain has
raised the threat level for British
forces in Iraq interestingly this
happened earlier in the week before a
British senior British officer made
comments that were downplaying the
threat to British and US and other
coalition assets in Iraq and comments
that were picked up upon by a lot of
media outlets to see as maybe this is
some kind of divergence of assessment
between the UK and the u.s. of the
threat that is being deemed to have been
posed by Iran that actually no that's
not the case I've been told that Major
General Chris Kika was fully aware of
the threat assessment that had been made
by the US and is also shared with the UK
and deemed credible by the UK but he
didn't feel as though whether he could
actually reveal that information
publicly which is why he played down the
threat at the time knowing fully that
actually the UK had like the u.s. raised
the threat level in Iraq I can also
reveal that British personnel and
families in Saudi Arabia Kuwait and
Qatar have also been put on a creased on
an increased state of alert as a result
to what sources say is this increased
threat posed by Tehran in terms of the
nature of the threat the backdrop is
obviously these escalating tensions
between the United States and Iran which
all began when Donald Trump pulled the
pulled the United States out of this
multinational deal with Iran to curb the
Iranian regime's nuclear ambitions
he pulled the United States out it's an
agreement that the UK and other allies
like France are still very much involved
in but the United States pilet pulled
out and then also imposed sanctions on
the Iranian regime and I'm told that
this new threat is is by the Iranians or
their proxies working in a way that they
could attack soft target
in a plausible plausibly deniable way so
as not to trigger an all-out war but
obviously if that is the intent then
clearly it shows why there is this risk
to British us and other assets in the
region and as a result they are making
these contingency steps I also
understand that in terms of the measures
to to safeguard personnel in those
countries Iraq Saudi Arabia Qatar and
Kuwait contingency plans are in place if
if the situation escalates further to be
able to bring people out of those
countries we're obviously a long way
from that yet and an awful lot of
diplomatic efforts are going on behind
the scenes I also understand that last
night Jeremy Hunt the Foreign Secretary
spoke to his counterpart in Oman Oman is
a has close relations with Iran and I
understand that the Foreign Secretary
was you know urging the emani's to use
their influence to try to help calm down
the situation it's obviously a very
tense time and and I we will have to see
how things develop from here